chris bassett looking to continue the
run he's been on as of late as i
highlighted kype three starts in a row
six innings two earned runs or less
and that last time against tampa the
nine punch-outs and as i mentioned it's
just about chris bassett settling in
early a guy who once he hits his stride
can be very tough to derail
and he gets simian waving at that slow
breaking ball we'll just take him out a
little farther and that's exactly what
chris bassett does you can see that side
spin not that big 69 70 mile an hour
uncle charlie that we're used to seeing
anders dies just tips off his glove and
bo buchet is going to have a base hit
let's see if laddie can get going for
just the second time all year guerrero
did not reach base in last night's game
overflow with a couple of strikeouts and
he's on base right here first page pitch
swinging he grounds it up the middle for
a base hit pushing bushette up to second
you know dan it looked like there was
some confusion between the second
baseman and the shortstop of who was
going to go get that ball was hit right
between them they're in the shift sinker
that stays up and watched lowry and
andrews both of them kind of stopped
they weren't really sure who was going
to go get that ball
because the other one had to take the
base at second base to try and get the
force blue jays will take it two men on
with one out now for the oscar hernandez
hitting 229 on the season
the swing and the fly ball right center
field and it's going to get down
piscotti couldn't see it because of the
sun the sheck coming around third
heading home and he's in there safely as
the blue jays catch a break
on what will go as an rbi single for
hernandez to give them an early
one-to-nothing lead you know i have
played the outfield here in oakland and
it is the toughest sunfield in all of
baseball right now
right field is the tough because it's
going to set right behind home plate and
watch piscotty normally a very good
outfielder he knows how tough it is
because he's got the glasses on already
tried to shade his eyes with the glove
he had no idea where that ball was and
he kept giving ground which is the right
thing to do good read from beau on that
now grichik he's hitting six of his last
seven runners at the corner is the pitch
and that's lifted into left center
that's gonna drop for a base hit
guerrero will score up the second is
hernandez the throw back behind him by
l'oreal but he's back to the bag grichik
and rbi single and now it's two nothing
toronto
four consecutive hits against bassett
and the curveball and guriel chased it
so a couple of strikeouts
but a couple of runs for the blue jays
bottom of the first coming up
but the blue jays have a guy who is
coming off back-to-back impressive
outings in robbie ray yeah he gets the
ball for his fifth start of the season
in that last start you were just
referencing it might have been his best
of the season
oh two and it's hit sharply to short
from the outfield grass bushette with a
very good play got a lot on the throw
and he gets canna by a step
boy what a play beau has been playing
shortstop a lot better lately and it all
has to do with his feet he keeps his
feet moving short choppy steps getting
himself in position to make the throw
and he's got plenty of arm to get canna
look at the movement right there he
looks at right into his glove takes his
time he'll one out here's laureano
goes after the first pitch at driveshaft
well right center field and that babies
go show the red hot ramon laureano
homers
again his fourth home run in the last
five games i mean the guy just continues
to stay hot and crush the baseball so
he's hitting balls a long ways
to right center
and how many times do you hear
hitters talk about you know when i'm
going good i'm feeling good i'm really
driving the ball the other way yeah that
would make perfect sense for loriento
now matt chapman stands in
he's drilled toward the gap in left
center field and that baby's gone
it stayed up and just kept going and
just cleared the wall
well matt chapman talked about making
that slow climb and that's exactly what
this slider did
slid down to the zone and not chopping
put it on a slow climb up and out of the
ballpark pack your bags folks
next stop pound town 2-2 game so the
blue jays bring the infield in with
murphy stepping in loriano excellent
speed at third base and the two-strike
pitch swung on bloop behind second base
racing out as pachette still going can't
get it it finds the grass and loriano
will waltz home with a go ahead run
a flare to center with the infield
pulled in murphy gets the rbi his tenth
of the year and oakland has a 3-2 lead
so now for the blue jays you've got the
tying run at third with just one out of
the eighth inning
vladimir guerrero jr at the plate
won't have to hit it that deep at the
speed of davis and that one gets through
allen
a low pitch gets through the legs of
allen to the backstop davis comes in to
score to tie the game the shed up to
second and it is 3-3 now let's see if t
oscar can give him the lead 2-1 to te
oscar and a liner into left field for a
base hit
the shed into score guerrero up to
second and the blue jays have taken the
lead
what a battle
what a battle they took the lead early
in the game just to watch oakland come
back take the lead
and now they have fought back to get the
lead again how about oscar calmly
being able to slow the game down and
taking that pitch and hitting it hard in
the left field
he has become such a
productive run producer because he's got
that ability now to slow the game down
richik lines one into left center and
that ball's going to get down for a base
hit bloody around third and heading home
the throw comes into second hernandez to
third and it is five three blue jays
and goriel with a little chopper to the
left side that will get another run home
as grichik comes in to score biggio to
third to give guerrielle an rbi
on the ground out the a's have some two
out magic here as
shaw murphy stands in
that one is drilled right center
nobody's gonna get it
olson digging for third davis picks it
up gets it in quickly they're gonna wave
him home the throw to the plate is not
in time as the ball pops out of
mcguire's glove
first and third one out
for vladimir guerrero jr
fastball
line left field and that ball is going
to get over the head of canna and all
the way to the fence
an absolute frozen rope off the bat of
vladimir guerrero jr will score a couple
of runs and it is 9-4
lots of heroes in the game tonight
offensively defensively and from the
pitching side 1-2 on the way and a
bouncing ball weekly hit to the right
side charging espinal has it on divisio
and that will do it